[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROGER MARTINEZ: Do
you have a large fleet
of staple virtual machines?
How many of each operating
system are there?
Which ones are fully patched
and up-to-date with the latest
security patches?
And can you be sure
that all of them
have the right software
installed and running?
For a lot of teams,
it's critical
that they're able to answer
all of these questions.
But that's not always
easy, especially
if your infrastructure
includes hundreds
of virtual machines running
various operating systems.
Today, I'm going to show you
how VM Manager can add clarity
to those questions and lift some
of those operational burdens
that come with managing a large
number of virtual machines
in the cloud.
VM Manager is a
suite of tools that
help you manage the operating
systems of your fleet
of virtual machines.
These capabilities
are nothing new.
There are plenty of third-party
tools and services out there
that help you do some of these
things across your fleet.
The advantage of VM Manager
is that it's cloud-native
and works out-of-the-box with
the latest Google Cloud images
across Windows and
Linux operating systems.
Its functionality is accessible
via the Google Cloud Console
that you're already
familiar with,
or via the gcloud command-line
interface and API.
VM Manager works by
periodically communicating
with the google-osconfig
agent that runs on each
of your virtual machines.
The data it receives
helps it serve three core
functionalities--
durability with OS
inventory management,
security with OS patch
management, and compliance
with OS configuration
management.
So let's talk about the first
VM Manager feature, OS inventory
management.
OS inventory management
lets you collect and review
operating system information
from your fleet of VMs.
This information includes
operating system version,
packages installed on each
VM, package updates available,
and vulnerability reports.
The osconfig agent
that periodically
reports in with the
latest data interfaces
with standard package
managers, like apt,
yum, and googet to collect
info on packages and updates.
So with OS inventory
management, I
can list all of the
VMs in my project.
And if I want, I can filter
that list by operating system,
by operating system version,
by installed packages,
by missing packages, or
even by pending updates.
Next, we have OS
patch management.
While OS inventory
management will tell you
what's installed where and
which updates are pending,
OS patch management
is going to let
you install packages and updates
through patch deployment jobs.
The OS Patch
Management Dashboard
will help you
visualize your fleet
and identify how many are
ready for updates, broken down
nicely by operating system.
The dashboard helps
you clearly identify
the machines in your fleet
that have important security
updates, so you'll
never miss a beat when
keeping the machines secure.
When you're ready
to deploy a patch,
you can create a
patch deployment job
to run immediately or
in the future, once
or on a recurring basis.
If a patch deployment
fails for whatever reason,
since VM Manager
is cloud-native,
you'll be able to troubleshoot
it right from the Cloud Console
through Cloud Logging.
The third big
piece of VM Manager
is OS configuration management.
With OS configuration
management,
you can automate the deployment,
configuration, and maintenance
of your virtual machines
from a centralized place.
You do this by creating
OS policies that
contain declarative
configuration for each VM,
like packages that
should be present,
package repositories
that should be added,
files that should exist, and
scripts that you'd like to run.
A single OS policy
can be written
to write a multi-step workflow.
For example, setting
up a repository,
installing a package, and
then changing config files.
You can specify how to
apply these policies
across your fleet
by using filters
based on labels, OS families,
or even regions and zones.
Once policies are
written and applied,
VM Manager will
constantly check to make
sure the policy is enforced.
It can also generate
a compliance report
that will tell you if any
machines have fallen out
of compliance with
the requirements
that you specified.
If you want to use VM Manager
with your fleet, here's how.
First, there are two APIs
that you'll want to enable
or your project, OS Config
and Container Analysis.
Then you need to enable OS
Config on each VM in your fleet
by setting the metadata tag
enable-osconfig to TRUE.
This will make
the osconfig agent
active on the
corresponding instances.
You also have the option
of adding this metadata
tag to your project so
that all VMs are included.
Each VM will also have to have
an attached service account.
It'll be used to sign
requests to the OS Config API.
And finally, each
VM in your fleet
is going to have to have the
osconfig agent installed.
The good news is
that this is already
included on the latest
OS images available.
If it isn't installed
on your machines,
check out the documentation
in the description
below for steps on how to get
it installed on each operating
system.
Let's check out VM Manager with
a quick walkthrough of OS patch
management.
What I have is a
Google Cloud project
with 17 virtual machines running
various operating systems.
For this demonstration, I have
the patch job executor IAM
role assigned.
That will give me permission
to create and execute
patch jobs in the project.
First, let's take a look
at the OS Patch Dashboard.
From here, we can see
our VMs broken down
by operating system.
We also see a chart for
each operating system,
showing us the virtual
machines by available updates.
If we click View Details
on any of those charts,
we'll get a list view
of our virtual machines.
Up here, we'll be able
to filter the list
by a few different fields.
For example, by adding a
Filter on OS Distribution,
we can view all CentOS
and Red Hat machines
in a single list with their
Zone, OS info, and Status.
If we want to get
more information
about a single machine's
available updates,
we can simply click the name
and get some more details.
Under Basic info, we once
again see the OS information
and a summary of its
available updates.
As you can see down here,
there are quite a few updates
with different Classifications.
Let's add a filter to see only
updates classified as Critical.
That narrows things down
to three critical updates.
If you want more information
about an individual update,
check out the CVE column.
You'll be able to go
straight to the CVE website
to learn more about the
vulnerability each update will
resolve.
Since these are
critical updates,
let's install these updates
by creating a patch job.
We can do that right here
by selecting the updates
and clicking Apply Update.
Creating a new patch deployment
happens with five steps.
First, let's select our VMs.
Our one CentOS machine is
automatically selected,
but we can add more by
adjusting the filter
and selecting all
CentOS machines.
Next is the Patch configuration.
First, we'll give it a name.
Since we initiated this straight
from the VM Details panel,
the packages we want to
update are already here
under Include packages.
We can move on to step
three, scheduling.
Here, we simply
indicate whether we
want to roll this deployment out
now or sometime in the future.
We also can create this
rollout on a recurring schedule
for packages that we know
we want to update regularly.
And the Duration
field will let us
specify how long
before the deployment
is considered a failure.
Step four brings us a
few more rollout options
that let us control how quickly
you want to roll it out.
The Threshold and
the Percentage will
help to slow down the
rollout so that we don't have
to patch all machines at once.
And finally, step five
is Advanced options,
where we can provide
VM Manager with any pre
or post-patch scripts that
we'd like to execute before
or after the patch completes.
Additionally, here, there are
some Post-patch reboot options.
Once we finish
the configuration,
we can click Deploy to kick
off this patch deployment job.
Once it starts, you can click
the job name on the Patch Jobs
page to get details
about its execution.
The Update info page will recap
what this job will be doing.
And on the bottom, we can see
the status of each VM included
in this patch deployment.
Once finished, each VM
will have the status
of Success or Failure,
along with a link
to view logs associated
with that patch job.
That was just a simple
example of OS patch management
in action and only a small peek
at what VM Manager as a whole
can do.
OS inventory management is
going to give you insight
into the operating
systems running
on your virtual machines in
your Google Cloud projects.
OS patch management will make
sure the right packages are
kept up-to-date and
free of vulnerabilities.
And OS configuration
management will
automate the deployment,
configuration, and maintenance
of your virtual machines--
all of this straight
from the Cloud Console.
For more information
on VM Manager,
check out the link
to the documentation
in the description below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]